what's the uh the queen so how did you
achieve the status of royalty the queen
of shitty robots what's the origin story
there
I I mean I have I have officially
renounced my title now can you still
speak of the time when you led you can
still speak of the tiger your kingdom
yes uh no I mean it started on because I
did you rule by love or fear by fear of
rejection
from me the people would reject me so I
uh yeah I started making these little
gifts like my the early projects that I
did were very gift forward
it was always like I only did it because
they could be translated into a gif give
forward I like it yeah but honestly it
was like it's a really good
mental exercise to vet if your project
is easy enough to be explained by like a
seven second looping video without audio
and
because like nobody's gonna care that it
also has Bluetooth like it's really like
is it is it self-explanatory enough to
um be explained through a gif so yeah
just pause outside to interrupt but I
feel like all scientific papers and
projects should go through that exercise
can you explain this again yeah actually
uh deepmind does a good job of this like
you know this we've solved protein
folding here's a gif that's literally
what they do yeah because who is going
to read the nature paper so like this
you have to like how do we communicate
this visually in a sexy clean way where
people can intuitively understand even
if you don't know what a protein is even
if you don't know what protein folding
is yeah it's very like yeah if somebody
comes out of context and that's been
really interesting also like building
this product business and trying to do
the marketing around that and I'm like
if somebody comes in and they have no
idea
about what this product is will they get
it explained to them in this ad and I
don't know but it's definitely a
worthwhile exercise to do so I started
making these projects that got
translated into gifts
and I posted them on slash R City robots
on Reddit does that subreddit existed
yeah and I loved it I thought it was
really fun and I was like I want to
contribute with content here conquered
it I don't I mean okay I don't know I
was through voted I think I was voted
top user of 2015. so yeah that's an old
Merit once you win a Nobel Prize you
always have the notebook okay so what
was the first do you remember the early
gifts that you created so this is when I
was at punch through design in San
Francisco I would kind of building a lot
of Hardware projects for them but I also
felt and they were so supportive of me
but also it's such a different way
representing a brand versus representing
yourself so there were some projects
that I just like ruled out because I was
like this feels too weird for this brand
and I started building them on the side
one of them was a toothbrush helmet and
yeah so it's like a skateboard helmet
with a robot arm on the forehead kind of
like a unicorn horn and it brushes your
teeth for you is that the first YouTube
video you uploaded it was the first gift
that I uploaded so actually I wanted to
um I wanted to do a kids show about
Electronics in Sweden because I was like
I love Electronics I think it's [__]
dope I could do a kids show about it so
I filmed this terrible terrible pilot
episode in my bedroom in San Francisco
and that's when I built the toothbrush
helmet and I emailed it to them I mean
just cold email like I'd know in or
anything I was like Hey I want to do
this and
um they didn't get back to me nobody's
surprised and I was like well I have
this
thing I built I might as well post it on
the internet so that's why I made the
little GIF and I posted it on your
robots and I think it got like 50 000
views and I was like Wow and from there
I just kept on building things and I
think Within
six months it was my full-time job can
you go through the detailed design of
this toothbrush helmet there's a motor
it's like a server like what what uh
what's the motor what's the is an
Arduino involved yeah so I
believe
um this robot arm called me arm
so it's just this acrylic robot arm and
um I think it has three Servo Motors
and it's all controlled by an Arduino
all the electronics already pre-built
there was a kit so I assembled it how do
you make sure the the length of the arm
is the proper I mean the arm came down
so it's like yeah and I just programmed
it to come down to my mouth and then
poorly brush my front teeth yeah yeah it
was just swung back and forth I mean
trialum error what was the challenges of
that
do you remember oh gosh or is that one
not much of a struggle challenge no it
was definitely a struggle
um because also how do you Loop it with
a nice gift
I mean it looks fine yeah it looks like
yeah that's not that's not that hard uh
no I mean it doesn't have to be perfect
it's a gif it's the internet things are
shitty all the time I think I mean I
think the biggest struggle of that was
that I had this intention for it to be
the show and then
them not giving oh yeah yeah giving back
and I was like well if they don't want
it then maybe YouTube will have me they
don't notice my genius yet